rester compétitif face au reste du monde
voici le principal objectif du nouveau
pôle de recherche et d'enseignement
supérieur de l'Université Paris
Grand-Ouest le séminaire inaugural se
tenait en fin de semaine dernière à
Saint-Germain en Lay devant un parterre
de 250 chercheurs scientifiques et
spécialistes en tout genre visiblement
très intéressés par cette fusion une
nouvelle structure regroupant les
différents pôles d'enseignement
supérieurs des Yvelines et du valdoise
soit 17 établissements 75 laboratoires
de recherche et quelques 45000 étud ire
un press c'est là pour apporter de la
valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire pour pouvoir
développer les projets que chacun des
établissements membres n'aurait pas pu
faire seul et puis de pouvoir travailler
en synergie avec les acteurs
socio-économiques du territoire c'est
dans cet esprit par exemple que nous
sommes en train de développer un
institut d'efficacité énergétique et des
énergies renouvelables sur Les Mureaux
porté principalement par l'Université de
versaill 5qu an en Yveline et de Sergi
Pontoise le Press a aussi dévoilé sa
première réalisation un Institut
d'Études Politiques ce sera le 10e en
France quand on voit le nombre de
candidatures qu'il y a par an au
concours d'entrée en première année on
se dit que il y a une très forte demande
et très peu d'offres il y a une volonté
aussi de faire de cet Institut d'Études
Politiques un institut très lié aux
universités fondatrices la dernière
année d'enseignement sera d'ailleurs
faite dans les deux universités dans les
masters des deux universités à
Versailles ou à Sergi ce qui fait que
nos étudiants seront dotés d'un double
diplôme à l'issue de leurs 5 ans de
formation ils seront diplôé de
l'Institut politique et d'un master de
l'une des deux universités rentré prévue
en 2013 dans ces locaux de Saint-Germain
en laai autre réalisation qui verra le
jour dans les prochains mois un institut
de la création qui travaillera sur
l'architecture et le paysage à noter
qu'il existe 25 press comme celui-ci en
France